okay but um in many situations we don't
actually have an equation it's nicely
because what we do have these had
particular points in time we just
measure we observe the experiment right
you're watching someone's to do you kept
on taking blood samples and you saw how
much my to you know how after one hour
two hours three hours okay
you have no derivative you've got no
equations you can't find out either of
these things but you can actually take
some measurements over time and compare
say for example this time so that time
you can see right instead of attention
you're gonna get a sequence like that I
should say because it and as opposed to
now tangent young this cord on this
secant in both the same thing in this
context it doesn't represent at a
specific point one it represents both
wrong also type right which is why we
call it rather than is the taste
we call it the average does that make
sense okay
so think about this way if I wanted to
know how Klein is increasing about how
steep it work however would I work this
out whose just you know a ground for no
was just after it's great in what what I
actually do how do you work that the
gradient of a what I would need to work
every father two points okay I'm gonna
need the rise and I'm gonna need the run
both of which I can get from the
coordinates right so I'm gonna play that
rise and then I'm gonna find out Ron and
then I'm going to divide that's all okay
but thief a thief on an exponential
growth situation okay what is the
horizontal axis what is that axis
usually that's usually the time axis
right so you've got like the time that
you start time one and you've got a time
that you end up Jews okay and then
what's the value axis if I'm actually an
auditorium actuary is Hall time right so
the vertical axis might be the
population of bacteria so you have the
population at a certain time and the
population had another time so if you're
an average grade right over this period
of time all it means is the gradient you
just need these pieces of information to
move into you're gonna get rise out of
this everybody out of that okay so
instead of writing y2 minus y1 which is
watch globally from color this must
normally on the top of my factory what
would be in place is y2 and y1 yeah it's
your population at the later time and
you're gonna compare that with the
population at the earlier time right
thank you
so that's going to be the rise have a
look at way you stock how you find out
that horizontal distance yeah it's your
later time takeaway you want other time
so this is just a reminder like I said
it looks like a really awkward would
date remember don't remember it just
remember that is greater than did you
get the right occasion
yeah this would be an absolute reference
like ah over that time it was it was a
back rating game three million bacteria
per hour okay but if I want that in a
proportional way what if I have lots
more bacteria or less you're gonna do
all the same things you're still going
to work out this rate this right here
now don't you might one of the best
writers project don't write this because
as you're going to say it's an awkward
way to write it I'm gonna write it it
need to wait but you don't understand
what I'm actually doing all you would do
is you take this ray and you would
compared that whole thing to whatever
your study population was okay you see
how open this is a later right but
that's what you're doing so for example
if I was just
oh you grew about 300 new bacteria 300
bacteria over the course of this hour
right is that is that a lot or is that a
little well it depends on how many
bacteria you started with yeah I suppose
I had a million bacteria in my body and
this is how fast they grew with that
would you describe this faster slower
super slow right like 300 out of a
million that's really slow but if I
started with 300 that means they've over
the course of the hour they've doubled
that's pretty fast time what if I
started with 10 bacteria older they cook
30 times more in because now and it's a
real trouble wait so in other words you
can you can be Nairn to your original
amount of bacteria that's what gives you
a sense proportionally about whether
this is this is fast
and you're in some serious trouble or
this is slow your immune system will
take over this okay so like I said I
didn't want you to write like this
because that ball could fracture another
fraction what would be a simpler way
once I simplify this we're with that
population of an T what will it go it
just goes up the denominator yeah so I
think a simpler way to write it is
it just ends up him he doesn't
population but the reason why is there
is could you divide that entire absolute
average growth rate by the population
that you started with
so weather isn't happening masters are
happening slow what depends on that guy
just one more thing where you have a
look at the boy I forgot to fill it in
the difference between absolute and
proportional is you're comparing to the
entire population if you have a big
population that will mean you know I
need to have big growth rate for it to
be a coin box so when you think about
hey you can actually think about it
through the same lens that is a rate but
your divided by however much you're
popular
okay here's the way I'm gonna show this
this might be your equation for a
population population at whatever time
but we can get a differential equation
out of this often because even doing
these questions right the first thing
you have to prove is that this guy's
satisfies a particular differential
equation Jeannette one was DP on DT
equals 1 K times P right okay now what
this means is if I rewrite this just a
teeny bit sorry I'm running out of space
literally I'm providing that is pink -
eat goose K Pig yet do you agree to that
that's just a reframing of what DPM two
teams now have a look at this equation
and tell me what K is what K is on the
basis of this equation when you change
the subject you have to do one operation
we do I'm ready to frig-in pretty good
right if I just want K just cave all I
have to do is divide by the population
as keep your time right doesn't have a
familiar it's the same deal right so do
you see how only he what you've got is a
gradient either at an instant in time or
over a period of time and then to have
an absolute growth rate into a
proportion worth right you just divide
by or convey to your population into the
people on or is it